hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel on how to
survive in the online jungle
ah there you are i didn't see you were
clearly hiding well the truth is we all
have something to hide admit it for sure
there are files on your computer that
you'd rather your friends and family
didn't know about i'm talking about old
diaries sketches of ideas for
revolutionary startup home videos
perhaps even some ultra private ones
with that old lady from the london
telephone box sticker
i think you know which one i'm talking
about you're out of it buddy you're
knocked out well so because of that
i'm going to explain today how you can
keep your digital secrets locked up
tight which methods you should use and
which you should wholeheartedly avoid
[Music]
now look contrary to popular belief it's
not that difficult to find a needle in a
haystack you could just burn the
haystack or use maybe a super magnet
right now the master of hide and seek
must actually hide this needle in a box
of other needles it's much more
difficult to find it then amongst those
that are similar or even identical
[Music]
the simplest and therefore the most
frequently used method of hiding data is
actually based on this principle i'm
talking about moving files to a
non-standard location or
metaphorical box of needles how dare you
use that word not in the standard my
documents folder but instead hide it
amongst the windows system folders now
the files in there measure in the tens
of thousands and it's unlikely that
someone curious would actually go
through all of them in search of some
secret folder
it's a pretty simple solution to be
honest and besides it doesn't require
any additional manipulations it's just
the reliability that becomes a concern i
mean the operating itself can actually
give you way for example it could show
the secret document a list of recently
opened files or recently used folders
and many programs also allow you to
quickly access these recent files i'm
sure that any passerby or guest user
would be intrigued by filename
mydiary.doc
therefore if you insist on releasing
this method use disguised file names
also don't be lazy by first saving the
document in a normal location for
instance on the desktop and then
manually moving into a secret folder
because it will still show up right
moreover to prevent it from accidentally
showing up when searching through
documents change its extension
mdr.dll in one of the system folders is
really unlikely to attract the attention
of your family members so remember a
collection of photos or videos can be
moved to one archive but don't forget to
change its extension too as you can
probably guess this is very basic hide
and seek literally the very first level
even a novice computer specialist
wouldn't have a hard time locating your
secrets now the fact of the matter is
that many programs leave characteristic
traces of the created files these are
known as signatures right for example
all docx documents have bike sequences
starting with
50 or 4b and jpeg pictures start with ff
or d8 now if the signature doesn't match
the file type it's definitely going to
attract the attention of a hacker or a
forensic expert now this method of
searching for hidden information is
called data carving so remember that now
the situation itself can be slightly
mitigated by the fact that individual
files can be protected with passwords
now this of course will provide
additional layers of protection against
prying eyes but it may cause unpleasant
questions from law enforcement agencies
what the hell are you yeah it depends a
lot on where you live i'm not talking
about the state or country in which you
live but the actual town or city let me
explain in 2017 two lawsuits in
california took place and they actually
ended with opposite results the
defendant in miami-dade who forgot his
password was released without charge but
in broad the guy was sentenced to 180
days in prison for hiding evidence
well in my homeland of the united
kingdom refusing to provide access to
one's computer is interpreted as hiding
evidence and the court will clearly not
be on your side even if you're saying
that you forgot the password right would
you risk it
[Music]
now the good news is that there are
programs that hide information the files
of other programs for instance you could
just add text to a photo or a music
track so that it will be invisible to
the naked eye or ear
[Music]
an ordinary color photo consists of
individual dots pixels right the color
of each of them is most often described
in 24 bit now if only two or three of
them are changed by a special algorithm
a couple of dozen pages of text can be
placed in one photo and the file won't
even change in size this method is
called steganography steganography has
long been known in hacker circles and
even became a key element in the
mysterious story of the cicada mystery
now i actually talked about this in one
of our past videos if you missed it be
sure to take a look over there i explain
this unique method in action but
obviously do it after this video i mean
we need the views besides it's like an
hour so you might want to save it for
your
tesco meal deal and your one-hour lunch
break right now the main disadvantage of
steganography is that for such a
concealment of information you do have
to use online services or install
additional programs to be honest i
definitely wouldn't recommend that
because you're effectively entrusting
confidential information with online
steganography services
at best the traces of working with them
will remain in the logs of your internet
provider and at worst well the hidden
text could be intercepted by intruders
and spread across the internet forever
now the very fact of installing and
using such software may attract extra
attention to you i mean if your computer
falls into the hands of a forensic
expert after discovery of such
steganographic programmes the police
will have a grand jubilee in questioning
you about it in addition photos that
containers for steganography give out
characteristic patterns of digital noise
and denying knowledge of their hidden
content will be much more difficult if
you have open puff or deep sound
installed
excuse me
the police are here
they asked for you
installing and then de-installing
programs every time i need to access
private information is just too much of
a tedious process i mean i suppose if
you don't visit that hideout often it
may be an option for example let's say
when saving the password to a crypto
rainy day fund you're not going to need
access to this wallet every single day
so you know uninstalling and
reinstalling programs might work
however for more day-to-day usage
situations i'd recommend dropping this
method in favor of
encrypted containers
[Music]
encrypted container is effectively a
securely encrypted folder that can be
only accessed with the correct password
in some ways it looks like a password
protected archive but there are
noticeable differences and also
advantages so let's talk about them the
first feature here is data encryption on
the fly if you're working with say an
encrypted archive you ought to first of
all completely decrypt it then you need
to make changes to decrypted files and
then well encrypt them again and then
after that you'd have to carefully
delete each one of the original files so
container encryption effectively allows
you to work with encrypted files just as
you worked with say a usb flash drive
it's enough to enter the password once
and then all the data stored within the
container will be decrypted and
encrypted on the fly without additional
actions on your part now the second
feature or advantage is that there's the
possibility of using two-factor
authentication when logging in the
program will first require you to enter
a password as usual but then it will
check for the presence of this file now
if it isn't present or it's not correct
access will subsequently be denied and
therefore even if an attacker finds out
or hacks your password you still won't
be able to crack open the container
without the key file now the use of key
files protects against things like key
loggers or trojans so it's quite good
the third feature here is that encrypted
containers do not betray their presence
with characteristic signatures like
those that we spoke about they just look
like a tiny piece of binary data on the
system and they're disguised as files
with a dot that extension so well they
look exactly the same and therefore
carving or signature isis will not help
to decrypt these encrypted containers if
it looks like a duck swims like a duck
and quacks like a duck it's probably a
mimic octopus furthermore the data of
the encrypted container can be deleted
in a matter of seconds the architecture
of the system is effectively designed so
that for the reliable destruction of
data in all encrypted containers it's
enough to just delete a very small
amount of data and without that data
it'd be impossible to decrypt the
remaining containers in addition you
could actually place the key file
just on an external drive like a usb
flash drive or an sd card which in case
of danger can easily be lost
and that's you know much easier to
believe than say forgetting your
password i really need to rethink my
target audience here and finally the key
feature of container encryption is the
use of double bottom technology now
inside an ordinary encrypted container
you can create a hidden one which only
you will know about basically works like
a safe within a safe now if external
circumstances such as criminal brute
force or say court decision force you to
give out your password for an encrypted
container that only your choice secrets
are going to be compromised right the
password that you've named will only
open one part of the archive the archive
you want them to see and your opponents
won't even suspect the other one your
secrets are your secrets alone
i just wanted to say i became aware
while writing this that such a video
might attract the attention of those who
are looking to hide legal materials such
as child pornography criminal evidence
or even lists of stolen bank details so
if that's you and you're out there i
just wanted to tell you that it's not a
good idea right go and live a normal
life don't risk prison your family or
even your social standing you have a
responsibility for making this world a
better place just think about that so
that's our official advice as a cyber
security company
but look i'm sure most you don't break
the laws and that's why throughout this
video you're probably thinking well hang
on bradley it's clear why criminals
would hide their files but why should i
bother i have nothing to hide from the
police well i'd like to remind all of
you about the video that we posted where
we bought a woman's laptop off of ebay
and we managed to recover all of the
wiped data i recovered their travel
history personal photos and even the
passport details of the former owner and
this is from a computer that was prepped
for sale right
now i'd like you to imagine that your
laptop is broken and you need to get it
serviced you sure there's nothing you'd
like to hide on your computer from raj
at the service center good old raj
might not be so trustful after all any
unprotected file is really easy to just
copy and send
this is a feature of our digital society
that cannot be ignored therefore do not
neglect your digital security keep your
secrets safe and don't forget to tune in
for more succulent fruits off the online
jungle so my name is bradley peak your
host and i'd like to thank you for
joining me on another motherly majestic
and mountainous medium rare almost murky
machiavellian masterclass on the online
jungle i will see you in the next video
thanks for joining us
[Music]
you